It intrigued me and I thought, "What else could I do?"
Could I do something in the public domain that would get the same reaction?
So I wrapped the stop sign pole near my house.
The reaction was wild.
People would park their cars
and get out of their cars and stare at it,
and scratch their heads and stare at it,
and take pictures of it and take pictures next to it,
and all of that was really exciting to me
and I wanted to do every stop sign pole in the neighborhood.
And the more that I did, the stronger the reaction.
So at this point I'm smitten.
I'm hooked.
This was all seductive.
I found my new passion
and the urban environment was my playground.
So this is some of my early work.
I was very curious about this idea of enhancing the ordinary,
the mundane, even the ugly,
and not taking away its identity or its functionality
but just giving it a well-tailored suit out of knitting.
And this was fun for me.
It was really fun to take inanimate objects
and have them come to life.
So ...
I think we all see the humor in this,
but --
(Laughter)
I was at a point where I wanted to take it seriously.
I wanted to analyze it.
I wanted to know why I was letting this take over my life,
why I was passionate about it,
why were other people reacting so strongly to it.
And I realized something.
We all live in this fast-paced, digital world,
but we still crave and desire something that's relatable.
I think we've all become desensitized
by our overdeveloped cities that we live in,
and billboards and advertisements,
and giant parking lots,
and we don't even complain about that stuff anymore.
So when you stumble upon
a stop sign pole that's wrapped in knitting
and it seems so out of place
and then gradually -- weirdly --
you find a connection to it,
that is the moment.
That is the moment I love
and that is the moment I love to share with others.
So at this point, my curiosity grew.
It went from the fire hydrants and the stop sign poles
to what else can I do with this material.
Can I do something big and large-scale and insurmountable?
So that's when the bus happened.
This was a real game changer for me.
I'll always have a soft spot in my heart for this one.
At this point, people were recognizing my work
but there wasn't much out there
that was wrapped in knitting that was large-scale,
and this definitely was the first city bus to be wrapped in knitting.
So at this point, I'm experiencing,
or I'm witnessing something interesting.
I may have started yarn bombing but I certainly don't own it anymore.
It had reached global status.
People from all over the world were doing this.
And I know this because I would travel to certain parts of the world
that I'd never been to,
and I'd stumble upon a stop sign pole and I knew I didn't wrap it.
So as I pursued my own goals with my art --
this is a lot of my recent work --
so was yarn bombing.
Yarn bombing was also growing.
And that experience showed me the hidden power of this craft
and showed me
that there was this common language I had with the rest of the world.
It was through this granny hobby --
this unassuming hobby --
that I found commonality with people
that I never thought I'd have a connection with.
So as I tell my story today,
I'd also like to convey to you
that hidden power can be found in the most unassuming places,
and we all possess skills that are just waiting to be discovered.
If you think about our hands, these tools that are connected to us,
and what they're capable of doing --
building houses and furniture,
and painting giant murals --
and most of the time we hold a controller or a cell phone.
And I'm totally guilty of this as well.
But if you think about it,
what would happen if you put those things down?
What would you make? What would you create with your own hands?
A lot of people think that I am a master knitter
but I actually couldn't knit a sweater to save my life.
But I did something interesting with knitting
that had never been done before.
I also wasn't "supposed to be" an artist
in the sense that I wasn't formally trained to do this --
I'm a math major actually.
So I didn't think this was in the cards for me,
but I also know that I didn't stumble upon this.
And when this happened to me, I held on tight,
I fought for it and I'm proud to say that I am a working artist today.
So as we ponder the future,
know that your future might not be so seamless.
And one day, you might be as bored as I was
and knit a door handle to change your world forever.
Thank you.
(Applause)